danke an deine Mama für dieses Rezept
das hier sind Spaghetti alla puttanesca
dafür brauchen wir Kapern Sardellen
schwarz Oliven grüne Oliven Petersilie
Tomaten Chili und Knoblauch mit
Knoblauch fange ich an einmal halbieren
und ganz fein hacken Olivenöl in die
Pfanne und Knoblauch hinterher zum
Knoblauch geben wir unsere Sardellen
zeitgleich Nudeln kochen hier das ganze
schön in Bewegung halten wollen es nicht
zu heiß haben wir helfen ein bisschen
mit dem Kochlöffel nach und gucken den
Sardellen beim schmelzenzug bisschen
Chili dazu hier ist ein Feuerwerk von
Düften in der Luft dazu jetzt Kapern
schwarze Oliven grüne Oliven wir sind
faul wir lassen einfach ganz und das
ganze ein bisschen durchschwenken
oder auch nicht jetzt nehmen wir
geschälte Tomaten geben im ersten Saft
dazu und quetschen dann die Tomaten rein
und durch Schwenken das mit dem
durchschwingen nur machen wenn es auch
könnt ich will Notebook ich riech das
und ich will nach Italien
in die Soße hinfallen aufstehen Krone
richten weitergehen wir schenken wieder
durch
doch frische Petersilie dran